This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Sandy Allen is a reporter and a writer. They live in upstate New York and they often go into New York City to run errands and go to meetings. And when they're out and about, finding an accessible bathroom can be a challenge. All right, so I'm on a university campus in New York City and there is a women's room and a men's room, and then a guy saw me sort of waiting to figure out what I was gonna do.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。桑迪·艾伦是一位记者兼作家。他们住在纽约州北部，经常去纽约市办事和开会。当他们在外面时，找到一个无障碍卫生间可能是一种挑战。好吧，我现在在纽约市的一所大学校园里，这里有女厕所和男厕所，然后有个男的看到我站在那儿，好像在琢磨我该怎么办。
This is a recording I made a few months back when I was in New York City. That's Sandy. This was before COVID, and I kept an audio diary of my bathroom search. He said to me, it's multiple referring to the men's room that he just exited, I think, because he thought I was
这是几个月前我在纽约市录的一段录音。那是桑迪。这是在新冠疫情之前，我一直用音频日记记录我寻找卫生间的过程。他对我说了话，他说的是“复数”，指的是他刚出来的那个男厕所，我想，因为他以为我
waiting to enter it. So, hurry, bathroom. For context, Sandy is non-binary and transgender. In terms of looking, quote-unquote male or quote-unquote female, I land somewhere in between. Some strangers call me sir, others call me maim, and so public restrooms always present this dilemma. In women's rooms, people look at me weird
在等候进入。所以，快点，卫生间。背景说明一下，桑迪是非二元性别者和跨性别者。就“所谓的”男性化或“所谓的”女性化外表而言，我处于两者之间。有些陌生人叫我先生，其他人叫我女士，所以公共卫生间总是带来这种困境。在女厕所里，人们用奇怪的眼光看我
or say mean things, but I'm often too afraid to go into men's rooms. I'm short, and I have this voice, and I worry that those traits could make me a target. It can feel risky and exhausting to navigate these two bad options. Okay, I'm in the New York City subway, and I didn't find it a bathroom earlier, and it's been hours, and that is pretty difficult, so I'm'm gonna just hold it for more hours. Okay. This particular day in New York I went the whole day without finding a bathroom I could use. And I've been out and about all day I haven't used the bathroom at
或者说些刻薄的话，但我通常太害怕进男厕所了。我个子矮，声音也这样，我担心这些特征会让我成为目标。在两个糟糕的选择之间徘徊会让人感到冒险和疲惫。好吧，我在纽约地铁里，之前没找到卫生间，已经过去好几个小时了，这真的很难，所以我打算再憋几个小时。好吧。在纽约的这一天，我整天都没找到一个能用的卫生间。我整天都在外面，我根本没用过卫生间，
all because I couldn't find one. I couldn't find one where I had a meeting earlier and I couldn't find one at my dentist's office. For many trans and non-binary and intersex people, this is the norm, really for anyone who doesn't conform to gender stereotypes. Some folks choose to risk the stress and sometimes physical danger that can come with entrained bathrooms
因为我找不到。我之前开会的地方找不到，在我牙医诊所也找不到。对于许多跨性别者、非二元性别者和双性人来说，这是常态，其实对于任何不符合性别刻板印象的人来说都是如此。有些人选择冒着压力，有时甚至是进入按性别隔离的卫生间可能带来的身体危险。
that are segregated by sex. Others choose not to. Instead, we hold it. Women's rooms and men's rooms, but there was no gender neutral option at all. Okay, bye. It's hard to overstate the effect this has had on my ability to exist in the world. I've stopped going to the gym.
另一些人选择不这样做。相反，我们憋着。女厕所和男厕所，但根本没有性别中立的选项。好吧，再见。很难夸大这对我在世界上生存的能力所产生的影响。我已经不去健身房了。
I hate to travel because my local airport doesn't have any bathrooms that work for me. Every trip out to a restaurant or a theater or really anywhere is laced with this underlying feeling of anxiety. And over many decades, this kind of bathroom-related anxiety has been a reality for lots of different kinds of people, not just trans people. Because ever since their invention, public bathrooms have been these sites of conflict about who's included in public life and who's excluded. Before widespread indoor plumbing, public restrooms didn't really exist. Instead, people used the privy, which was basically just a hole in the ground, sometimes with a little outhouse style building. By and large privies were not segregated by
我讨厌旅行，因为我当地的机场没有任何适合我的卫生间。每一次去餐馆、剧院或任何地方的行程都夹杂着这种潜在的焦虑感。几十年来，这种与卫生间相关的焦虑一直是许多不同类型人的现实，不仅仅是跨性别者。因为自发明以来，公共卫生间一直是关于谁被纳入公共生活、谁被排除在外的冲突场所。在室内管道普及之前，公共卫生间并不真正存在。相反，人们使用厕所，那基本上只是地上的一个洞，有时带有一个小棚屋式的建筑。总的来说，厕所并没有按
sacks, nor were they segregated by class. The outdoor privy was used by rich and poor alike across the United States. That's Terry Cogan, a professor of law at the University of Utah. He is basically the expert about the history of sex-segregated bathrooms in the US. And he says that it wasn't until the mid-1800s that indoor restrooms started to become a thing. Beginning in the late 1840s and 1850s, cities began developing municipal works, water works and sewerage systems that actually could accommodate indoor water closets. So once that came about, the outdoor privy was replaced by indoor water closets. At first, it was only the very wealthy who could afford this latest in plumbing technology.
性别隔离，也没有按阶级隔离。在美国，无论贫富，人们都使用户外厕所。那是特里·科根，犹他大学的法学教授。他基本上是美国按性别隔离卫生间历史方面的专家。他说，直到19世纪中期，室内卫生间才开始出现。从19世纪40年代末和50年代开始，城市开始发展市政工程、供水工程和排污系统，这些系统实际上可以容纳室内抽水马桶。所以一旦这些出现，户外厕所就被室内抽水马桶取代了。起初，只有非常富有的人才能负担得起这种最新的管道技术。
Having a bathroom inside your house was a luxury. But gradually indoor water closets became more widespread, and as they moved into the public realm, they entered a world that was at the time shaped by this very popular idea, which was called the Separate by this very popular idea, which was called the separate spheres ideology. And that ideology basically said that women should remain in the home and men's appropriate realm is in public, in politics, working in factories, whatever. And this vision was very, very powerful.
家里有卫生间是一种奢侈。但渐渐地，室内抽水马桶变得更加普及，当它们进入公共领域时，它们进入了一个当时被这种非常流行的思想所塑造的世界，这种思想被称为“独立领域意识形态”。这种意识形态基本上认为女性应该留在家里，而男性的适当领域是在公共场合、政治中、在工厂工作等等。这种愿景非常、非常强大。
Allowing women into the public sphere was thought to be risky, because given their weakness, they could become contaminated by the vile influence of men. I mean, I'm also worried about being contaminated by the vile influence of men. Yeah, I get it, but what you have to understand is, back then, the idea would have been about literal contamination. It was then considered consensus among scientists who were basically all men that women were weak and vulnerable and susceptible to disease. But women, of course, were not weak, nor were they actually confined to the home.
允许女性进入公共领域被认为是冒险的，因为鉴于她们的软弱，她们可能会被男性的邪恶影响所污染。我的意思是，我也担心被男性的邪恶影响所污染。是的，我明白，但你必须明白的是，在当时，这个想法指的是字面意义上的污染。当时在科学家（他们基本上都是男性）中达成的共识是，女性是软弱、脆弱且易受疾病感染的。但女性当然并不软弱，也没有被限制在家里。
By the early 19th century, more women than ever were working and getting involved in politics. So one is faced in the first part of the 19th century with this tension, that the cultural ideology said women should be in the home, and the reality was that women were leaving their home in ever-increasing numbers. And American building designers had to find a way to navigate this tension. They had to figure out how to create public spaces that both accommodated women, but still kept up this ruse of women being relegated to the home.
到了19世纪初，工作的女性比以往任何时候都多，也更多地参与政治。因此，在19世纪上半叶，人们面临着这种张力：文化意识形态说女性应该待在家里，而现实是女性正以越来越多的数量离开家。美国的建筑设计师必须找到一种方法来应对这种张力。他们必须弄清楚如何创造既能容纳女性，又能维持女性被贬低在家庭中的假象的公共空间。
The solution they came up with was to segregate public space. They designed ladies-only train cars and ladies-only dining rooms and waiting rooms. And these spaces were often decorated to look very domestic, with the sort of sofas and wallpaper and drapery you'd see in an upper-middle-class living room. And the thinking was that for those ladies who dare to venture into this dangerous public world, these are protective spaces for them. And so these living, roomy, looking women's spaces became a fixture of public life across
他们想出的解决方案是隔离公共空间。他们设计了女性专用火车车厢、女性专用餐厅和候车室。这些空间通常被装饰得看起来非常居家，配有你在中上层阶级客厅里会看到的沙发、壁纸和窗帘。当时的想法是，对于那些敢于冒险进入这个危险公共世界的女士们来说，这些是保护性的空间。因此，这些看起来像客厅的女性空间成为了全美公共生活的一部分。
America. And that meant that when toilets eventually moved inside to places like theaters and restaurants, they were also segregated by sex. Gradually, as the 19th century went on, society started to desegregate the sexes. But even as men and women started mixing more, segregated bathrooms stuck around. They're a vestige of this ideology that once insisted that men and women couldn't share public space at all. And one of the reasons that segregated bathrooms have proved so enduring is that these separate facilities were actually codified into law.
这意味着当厕所最终搬进剧院和餐馆等场所时，它们也按性别进行了隔离。渐渐地，随着19世纪的推移，社会开始打破性别隔离。但即使男女开始更多地融合，隔离的卫生间依然存在。它们是这种意识形态的遗迹，这种意识形态曾经坚持认为男女根本不能共享公共空间。隔离卫生间之所以被证明如此持久，原因之一是这些独立的设施实际上被编入了法律。
The first laws were passed in the 1880s, and they had to do with women factory workers, and how they needed a space where they could rest when their weak female bodies gave out. With its vision of women as vulnerable beings who needed protection. weak female bodies gave out. But the history of public bathrooms isn't just about who is seen as worthy of protection. It's also about who is seen as unworthy. There have been many waves of panic and resistance to new people moving into the public sphere and needing accommodation. And a focus of that panic has
第一批法律是在19世纪80年代通过的，它们与女性工厂工人有关，以及当她们虚弱的女性身体支撑不住时，她们需要一个可以休息的空间。这种愿景将女性视为需要保护的脆弱存在。但公共卫生间的历史不仅仅是关于谁被视为值得保护。它也关于谁被视为不值得。在新的群体进入公共领域并需要安置时，曾出现过许多恐慌和抵制的浪潮。而这种恐慌的焦点往往是
often been public bathrooms. So yeah, I mean pretty much every decade there's been some controversy about public toilets. This is Professor Susan Striker. She's written, among many works, a groundbreaking book called Transgender History. And she says that for as long as we've had public restrooms, we've had battles about who belongs in them and who doesn't. And she thinks that we fight about bathrooms partly because they're these very charged spaces. We have always to have booze around waste and elimination
公共卫生间。所以，是的，我的意思是几乎每十年都会出现一些关于公共厕所的争议。这是苏珊·斯特赖克教授。她在众多著作中写过一本名为《跨性别历史》的开创性书籍。她说，只要我们有公共卫生间，我们就会有关于谁属于这里、谁不属于这里的争论。她认为我们争论卫生间的部分原因是它们是非常敏感的空间。我们总是对排泄和
and privacy and smell. And it's very difficult for people to think rationally about some of these things. We just react at an emotional level. And Professor Striker says, pick a moment in 20th century American history, and chances are there was some sort of freak out about some group of marginalized people using the bathroom. With the rise of more visible gay and lesbian communities in the years after World War 2, there were
隐私以及气味感到不安。人们很难理性地思考其中一些事情。我们只是在情感层面上做出反应。斯特赖克教授说，随便挑一个20世纪美国历史上的时刻，很可能都会出现某种关于边缘群体使用卫生间的恐慌。随着二战后同性恋群体变得更加可见，出现了
panics about gay male sex and public toilets. There was a sense of gay men being predatory, you know, to straight men. By the 1950s and 60s, activists began challenging codes of racist segregation in the South. This included challenges not just to racially segregated water fountains, lunch counters, and buses, but to racially segregated bathrooms. If you think back to any signs that you might have seen from the battle days of Jim Crow, it was not uncommon to see public coilets labeled men, women, colored.
关于男同性恋在公共厕所发生性行为的恐慌。有一种感觉是男同性恋对异性恋男性具有掠夺性。到了20世纪50年代和60年代，活动家们开始挑战南方的种族隔离准则。这不仅包括对种族隔离的饮水机、午餐柜台和公共汽车的挑战，还包括对种族隔离卫生间的挑战。如果你回想一下你在吉姆·克劳法时代的黑暗日子里可能看到的任何标志，看到标有“男”、“女”、“有色人种”的公共厕所并不罕见。
With the rise of the feminist movements, you saw in the 60s and 70s, particularly around efforts to pass the Equal Rights Amendment that you had right-wing people who were opposed to the Equal Rights Amendment saying, oh, they're going to require unisex bathrooms. Already we go to the same bathrooms on airplanes and buses. Does this mean that with the Equal Rights Amendment, if it is passed, that there will no longer be men and women on the doors, but us or we or whatever?
随着女权运动的兴起，你在60年代和70年代看到了，特别是在努力通过《平等权利修正案》的过程中，有右翼人士反对《平等权利修正案》，说：“哦，他们将要求男女通用卫生间。我们已经在飞机和公共汽车上使用同一个卫生间了。这是否意味着如果《平等权利修正案》通过，门上将不再有男女之分，而是‘我们’或别的什么？”
Well, that's... By the 80s, you know, you have the AIDS crisis. It's a disease first detected in the gay community that has now spread beyond that. A disease. And, you know, there was another wave of panic around public toilets. You're gonna get AIDS there.
好吧，那是……到了80年代，你知道，艾滋病危机爆发了。这是一种首先在同性恋群体中发现，现在已经蔓延到该群体之外的疾病。一种疾病。而且，你知道，围绕公共厕所又出现了一波恐慌。你会因为在那里而感染艾滋病。
The ADA ensures access to public toilets, you're going to get AIDS there. The ADA ensures access to public accommodations such as restaurants, hotels, shopping centers, and offices. The Americans with Disabilities Act is passed in 1990. And again, there's a wave of, oh, it's going to be too expensive and why do we have to accommodate those people? Which brings us to the bathroom-related panic of today, which is about people like me and like Professor Striker.
《美国残疾人法案》确保了对公共厕所的访问权，你会因为在那里而感染艾滋病。《美国残疾人法案》于1990年通过。同样，又出现了一波“哦，这太贵了，为什么我们要迁就那些人？”的浪潮。这把我们带到了今天的卫生间相关恐慌，也就是关于像我和斯特赖克教授这样的人的恐慌。
A moral panic around trans people. Today, the legal battle over which bathrooms transgender individuals can use in North Carolina is becoming more heated by the day. This debate about trans-bathroom access became a big national story a little over five years ago. You had ordinances or proposed ordinances in states like North Carolina and Texas, which attempted to restrict which bathrooms trans people could or couldn't use. Terry Cogan thinks this surge in anti-trans-bathroom activism has something to do with the Supreme Court allowing for gay marriage in 2015.
围绕跨性别者的道德恐慌。今天，关于跨性别者在北卡罗来纳州可以使用哪些卫生间的法律斗争正变得日益激烈。这场关于跨性别者卫生间使用权的辩论在五年多前成为了一个重大的全国性新闻。在北卡罗来纳州和德克萨斯州等地，出现了试图限制跨性别者可以使用或不能使用哪些卫生间的法令或拟议法令。特里·科根认为，这种反跨性别卫生间激进主义的激增与最高法院在2015年允许同性婚姻有关。
After that happened, all the conservative money and energy that had gone into that fight had to find a new target. This conservative energy coalesced around trans people and their desire to use the restroom that accords not with their birth sex but with their gender identity. People on both sides of this debate claim that they're on the side of safety. One side says, hey, trans people deserve bathrooms where they can feel safe. The other side says women shouldn't be attacked in the bathroom by cross-dressing men. But as Professor Striker describes, this notion of a predatory cross-dressing man is a fiction. That fear is completely phantasmatic. It's like, show me the police reports of cross-dressed male sex predators in public toilets. It's like, I don't think you can find one.
在那之后，所有投入到那场斗争中的保守派资金和精力都必须找到一个新的目标。这种保守派的能量围绕着跨性别者以及他们想要使用不符合出生性别、而是符合其性别认同的卫生间的愿望而凝聚起来。这场辩论双方的人都声称他们站在安全的一边。一方说，嘿，跨性别者应该拥有让他们感到安全的卫生间。另一方说，女性不应该在卫生间里被异装癖男性攻击。但正如斯特赖克教授所描述的那样，这种“掠夺性异装癖男性”的概念是虚构的。那种恐惧完全是幻觉。就像是，给我看看公共厕所里异装癖男性性掠夺者的警察报告。我觉得你一个都找不到。
It's a fear, it's that effect. In reality, if you look at the numbers, it is trans people who are at greatest risk of being attacked in public restrooms. According to Professor Kogan, if you look at surveys of trans people. The number is roughly 70% have experienced either verbal or physical abuse, and among some populations, in particular, black trans women, the level of abuse is much higher.
这是一种恐惧，这是一种影响。实际上，如果你看数据，跨性别者才是公共卫生间中最容易受到攻击的群体。根据科根教授的说法，如果你查看跨性别者的调查，大约70%的人经历过言语或身体虐待，而在某些群体中，特别是黑人跨性别女性，虐待程度要高得多。
I sometimes find my friends who aren't queer really don't seem to understand just how dangerous public restrooms can be for me. How every time I want a pee or wash my hands, I do a calculus about my likelihood of being endangered by some random person. I don't know a trans person who doesn't have a story or many about being harassed by a stranger. Like, I was talking with Seb Chah,
我有时发现我的非酷儿朋友似乎真的不明白公共卫生间对我来说有多危险。每当我想要小便或洗手时，我都会计算一下我被某个随机的人伤害的可能性。我不认识一个没有被陌生人骚扰过故事或多个故事的跨性别者。比如，我正在和塞布·查交谈，
who's an architect in South Carolina, and they told me this story about going to a swimming pool with their partner. After getting exercise, you went to go use the sauna, because sauna's a great. But Seb faced a problem, which was there was a locker room for women
他是一位南卡罗来纳州的建筑师，他们告诉我这个关于和伴侣去游泳池的故事。锻炼完后，你去使用桑拿房，因为桑拿很棒。但塞布面临一个问题，那就是有一个女性更衣室
and a locker room for men. I was already kind of apprehensive because I'm trans non-binary. So Seb and their partner picked the women's room because that was for them the better of the two available options. I knew that I could probably come up against some friction, but I felt a responsibility to use the sauna, where I felt like I belonged more.
和一个男性更衣室。我已经有点忧虑了，因为我是跨性别非二元性别者。所以塞布和他们的伴侣选择了女厕所，因为对他们来说，这是两个可用选项中较好的一个。我知道我可能会遇到一些摩擦，但我感到有责任使用桑拿房，在那里我觉得我更属于那里。
We were in the sauna for a little bit, and this middle-aged white woman enters, and asked me to leave because she wants to use the sauna. And I calmly told her that she was welcome to join and use the sauna with us. And she kind of left it a half and brought back this male staff member who asked me to leave. Everyone watched as Seb was escorted out of the locker room. It was humiliating, it was isolating, it was also for a trans person, an entirely ordinary experience.
我们在桑拿房里待了一会儿，一个中年白人女性进来了，要求我离开，因为她想用桑拿房。我平静地告诉她，欢迎她加入并和我们一起使用桑拿房。她有点生气地离开了，带回了一个男性工作人员，要求我离开。每个人都看着塞布被护送出更衣室。这很羞辱人，很孤立，但对于跨性别者来说，这是一种完全普通的经历。
Like, this kind of thing happens to us all the time. And it's generally a pretty horrible feeling of exclusion just trying to use the sauna. It's the most mundane stuff that we have to think twice about, whether to swim, whether to use a changing room. Even for somebody like Professor Striker, who's lived out of the closet for decades. I transitioned surgically and socially back in the 90s. I still look over my shoulder when I go in to the women's room. Every single time, it's like, hmm, is somebody going to notice something? Are they going to freak out? Is this going to be a scene?
像这样的事情一直发生在我们身上。这通常是一种非常可怕的被排斥的感觉，仅仅是因为试图使用桑拿房。这是我们必须三思而后行的最平凡的事情，是否游泳，是否使用更衣室。即使对于像斯特赖克教授这样几十年来一直公开生活的人来说也是如此。我在90年代进行了手术和社交转型。当我走进女厕所时，我仍然会回头看。每一次，就像是，嗯，有人会注意到什么吗？他们会抓狂吗？这会闹出什么事吗？
A lot of us who are trans going to call it the tax. You know, it's part of the tax you get taxed just for walking around being trans in the world. And part of the trans tax is like always being mindful of moving into those sex-segregated spaces. moving into those sex-segregated spaces. But even though we take it for granted that most public restrooms are segregated by sex, they don't have to be this way. And as the debates around trans-bathroom access began heating up, one architect began thinking about exactly that. My name is Joel Sanders.
我们很多跨性别者称之为“税”。你知道，这部分税是你仅仅因为作为跨性别者在世界上走动而被征收的。跨性别税的一部分就是总是注意进入那些按性别隔离的空间。但尽管我们认为大多数公共卫生间按性别隔离是理所当然的，但它们不必非得这样。随着围绕跨性别者卫生间使用权的辩论开始升温，一位建筑师开始思考这个问题。我叫乔尔·桑德斯。
I'm an architect with a practice based in New York called JSA. Joel had long been interested in bathrooms. As a gay man during the height of the AIDS epidemic, he remembered how public restrooms had become a flashpoint back then. And he was especially interested in the lack of attention his fellow architects seemed to pay to these spaces. I think for society, the bathroom is the ultimate sort of functionalist architecture. It doesn't require design, it doesn't require creativity.
我是一位在纽约执业的建筑师，事务所叫JSA。乔尔长期以来一直对卫生间感兴趣。作为一名在艾滋病流行高峰期的男同性恋者，他记得当时公共卫生间是如何成为冲突焦点的。他特别关注他的建筑师同行似乎对这些空间缺乏关注。我认为对于社会来说，卫生间是终极的功能主义建筑。它不需要设计，不需要创造力。
But the reality is, is that bathroom design does matter, whether architects realize it or not. When they design public bathrooms, they're deciding who's included and who's excluded when it comes to fully participating in public life. Joel figured if they put their minds to it, architects could reimagine bathrooms entirely. And so I picked up the phone and I reached out to a colleague of mine who I'd met many, many years before named Susan Striker. What a coincidence. Susan Striker was just here, let me go get her. You know, we just started talking, you know. We would, you know, have long rambling phone calls with each other about it.
但现实是，卫生间设计确实很重要，无论建筑师是否意识到这一点。当他们设计公共卫生间时，他们决定了在充分参与公共生活方面，谁被纳入，谁被排除。乔尔想，如果他们用心去想，建筑师可以完全重新构想卫生间。所以我拿起电话，联系了我多年前认识的一位同事，名叫苏珊·斯特赖克。真是巧合。苏珊·斯特赖克刚才就在这儿，让我去叫她。你知道，我们刚开始交谈，你知道。我们会进行长时间的、漫无边际的电话交谈。
And in these calls, Susan and Joel started identifying all the ways that bathrooms suck to use an architectural term. Not just for trans people, but for pretty much everyone. I think that public toilets don't work well for most people. They could be people who are breastfeeding. People who might need to do medical care of some kind, like maybe they need to take their insulin. People with urinary tract infections.
在这些通话中，苏珊和乔尔开始识别出卫生间在建筑术语上“糟糕”的所有方式。不仅是对跨性别者，对几乎所有人都是如此。我认为公共厕所对大多数人来说都不好用。可能是正在哺乳的人。可能需要进行某种医疗护理的人，比如他们可能需要注射胰岛素。患有尿路感染的人。
You know, the dad who's got the daughter and he doesn't want her to go into the bathroom by herself. Muslims who perform bathroom evolutions. There's also the problem of unequal bathroom lines. You go to the theater and an intermission. You know, there are huge lines of women waiting and smaller if no lines in the men's room. The buildery term for this is overload.
你知道，带着女儿的父亲，他不想让她一个人进卫生间。进行卫生间清洁的穆斯林。还有卫生间排队不平等的问题。你去剧院看中场休息。你知道，女厕所里有长长的队伍，而男厕所里队伍很短，甚至没有。建筑学术语称之为“过载”。
Then there are the problems many people with physical disabilities have with public restrooms. Joel Sanders was introduced by a mutual friend to Quimelle Aroio. He uses a wheelchair and used to advise the New York City Department of Transportation about accessibility. He met up with Joel for dinner. And it was an instant love fest. I mean, we spoke for hours. Quimelle detailed all these horrible experiences he'd had with public bathrooms.
还有许多身体残疾的人在公共卫生间遇到的问题。乔尔·桑德斯通过一位共同的朋友认识了奎梅尔·阿罗约。他使用轮椅，过去曾为纽约市交通局提供无障碍建议。他和乔尔共进晚餐。那是一场即时的“爱之盛宴”。我的意思是，我们谈了几个小时。奎梅尔详细描述了他使用公共卫生间时遇到的所有可怕经历。
Like, when he was at an airport and had to search everywhere for a stall that was big enough to fit his chair inside, and in the end, he couldn't. And I ended up having to use a stall and lead the door open behind me because I literally couldn't shut the door behind me. And then there are the horrors of public restroom sink design. I spoke about how pissed off I'd get when I'd use a sink and because it was a flat top surface, the
比如，当他在机场时，不得不到处寻找一个足够大、能容纳他轮椅的隔间，最后却没找到。我最终不得不使用一个隔间，并把门开着，因为我真的无法把门关上。还有公共卫生间洗手池设计的恐怖之处。我谈到当我使用洗手池时会多么生气，因为那是一个平坦的顶部表面，
water would drip down onto my pants. When Mel sees all this bad design as a failure of imagination, so many of these quote unquote accessible bathrooms still don't get it. And they don't get it because they're being designed by people who don't understand accessibility. And so Joel Sanders kept imagining what an actually inclusive public bathroom might be like. He kept talking to Susan Striker on the phone and the two began meeting up and then collaborated on an academic paper and then... To make a long story short, we received so much interest in the design community and really in the general public that we founded Stald. That's Stald with an exclamation point, as in the bathroom stall, but also how this whole
水会滴到我的裤子上。奎梅尔认为所有这些糟糕的设计都是想象力的失败，这么多所谓的“无障碍”卫生间仍然没搞懂。他们没搞懂是因为它们是由不了解无障碍设施的人设计的。所以乔尔·桑德斯一直在想象一个真正包容的公共卫生间会是什么样子。他一直在电话里和苏珊·斯特赖克交谈，两人开始见面，然后合作撰写了一篇学术论文，然后……长话短说，我们在设计界和公众中获得了如此多的兴趣，以至于我们成立了“Stalled”。那是带有感叹号的“Stalled”，既指卫生间隔间，也指整个
bathroom debate is totally stalled out. The Stald project would tackle not merely the problem of trans-bathroom access, but totally reconsive of the bathroom so that it works way better for way more kinds of people. But Susan and Joel quickly hit a big snare. The code. Right now for public buildings over a certain size, the building code mandates that you must build what are termed separate facilities, meaning a women's room and a men's room. We could come up with design solutions, but unless they're legally implementable, they're building codes, and laws and public policies, they're not going to happen.
卫生间辩论是如何完全陷入停滞的。Stalled项目不仅要解决跨性别者卫生间使用权的问题，还要完全重新构想卫生间，使其对更多类型的人更有效。但苏珊和乔尔很快遇到了一个大障碍。法规。目前，对于超过一定规模的公共建筑，建筑规范强制要求必须建造所谓的“独立设施”，即女厕所和男厕所。我们可以提出设计方案，但除非它们在法律上可实施，即建筑规范、法律和公共政策，否则它们不会发生。
So, they called up the country's foremost thinker on laws about bathrooms. They needed someone who, in a sense, could deal with the legal issues. Terry Cogan was thrilled when he got this call. He told me Joel and Susan were actually two of his intellectual heroes, and so he jumped at the chance to join the project. And then Joel happened to meet Seb. I was introduced to Joel after the lecture by a friend who knew him. Seb was graduating from the Architecture Program at Columbia, and Seb joined the project too as did Quimelle. I believe that people want to be invited to participate.
所以，他们打电话给全国最顶尖的卫生间法律思想家。他们需要一个在某种意义上能处理法律问题的人。特里·科根接到这个电话时非常激动。他告诉我，乔尔和苏珊实际上是他心目中的两位知识英雄，所以他抓住机会加入了这个项目。然后乔尔碰巧遇到了塞布。我在讲座后通过一位认识他的朋友被介绍给乔尔。塞布当时正从哥伦比亚大学建筑系毕业，塞布也加入了这个项目，奎梅尔也加入了。我相信人们希望被邀请参与。
These people are coming together like the Avengers of inclusive bathroom design. It's the Avengers, but more queer and about bathrooms. And so the stall team at last assembled got to work, fighting their arch-nemesis, sex-segregated bathrooms. Terry and his colleagues began spearheading illegal appeal to change the code, and the architects got to work totally re-envisioning designs for certain public bathrooms, like once for elementary schools and once for airports. Why airports? Because it seems to be a place where there's a high quantity of diverse bodies, spending a lot of time and
这些人聚在一起，就像包容性卫生间设计的“复仇者联盟”。这是复仇者联盟，但更酷儿，而且是关于卫生间的。于是，Stalled团队终于组建完毕，开始工作，对抗他们的宿敌——按性别隔离的卫生间。特里和他的同事们开始带头进行法律上诉以修改规范，建筑师们开始致力于为某些公共卫生间重新构想设计，比如小学和机场的卫生间。为什么是机场？因为那里似乎是一个拥有大量多样化身体的地方，花费大量时间，
also having to address their embodied needs. In totally reimagining the airport bathroom, the first thing this old team did was get rid of the idea that the bathroom is a room with a door. Instead, the airport bathroom is now conceptually an extension of the public space, like a big lounge. This space is then divided into three activity zones. So activity zone number one is grooming, and they're proposing a counter. But not just a counter at the height of a standard able bodied adult, but one that
并且必须满足他们的身体需求。在完全重新构想机场卫生间时，Stalled团队做的第一件事就是摆脱“卫生间是一个带门的房间”的想法。相反，机场卫生间现在在概念上是公共空间的延伸，就像一个大休息室。这个空间被划分为三个活动区。所以活动区一号是梳洗，他们提议设置一个柜台。但不是一个标准健全成年人高度的柜台，而是一个
unrelates at different levels. With mirrors also of varying heights, and it would allow people of different heights and abilities to groom together a public space. Activities zone number two is hand washing. Doing away with that traditional countertop, that Coimel Arroyo and other wheelchair users hate so much. Instead of individual sinks, stalled proposes a water wall with a splash plane that's angled slightly away from the user.
在不同高度的柜台。镜子的高度也各不相同，这将允许不同身高和能力的人在公共空间一起梳洗。活动区二号是洗手。摒弃了奎梅尔·阿罗约和其他轮椅使用者非常讨厌的传统台面。Stalled提议使用一个带有防溅板的水墙，防溅板与用户略微倾斜。
It would not be at one standard height, but it would be at multiple heights, again, to accommodate children, elderly, different body heights and weights. The water itself would be recycled to water plants, which would help bring a sense of calm to the space. Which brings us to activity zone number three. A kind of continuous wall of differently sized stalls. And again, it's key that they need to be of different sizes. Some would be standard.
它不会是一个标准高度，而是多个高度，再次为了容纳儿童、老人、不同身高和体重的人。水本身会被循环利用来浇灌植物，这将有助于给空间带来一种平静感。这把我们带到了活动区三号。一种连续的、不同尺寸的隔间墙。同样，关键是它们需要有不同的大小。有些是标准的。
Others would be larger for people with mobility issues, people in wheelchairs. And the stalls would ideally be totally floor to ceiling to provide maximum privacy. The stall bathrooms include other details that would make them more welcoming for all kinds of people, like foot washing stations for Muslim people and floor materials that make the space easier for people with vision impairments to navigate. All of this is more inclusive, and it's also safer, because instead of being divided
另一些会更大，供有行动障碍的人、轮椅使用者使用。理想情况下，隔间应该是完全从地板到天花板的，以提供最大的隐私。Stalled卫生间包括其他细节，使它们对各种人更友好，比如为穆斯林提供的洗脚台，以及使视障人士更容易导航的地板材料。所有这些都更具包容性，也更安全，因为不再被划分为
into two or sometimes three groups, men, women, and disabled, in this reimagined bathroom, all people can monitor a single common space. One quickly sees that these are open spaces which provide, in a sense, double the eyes on the street. So these bathroom avengers had defeated one foe, the idea that public bathrooms could only ever be sex segregated. But that left one more front in this war, the legal one, the battle between Terry Cogan and the body that governs the building code. Virtually every state and municipality in America and in many foreign countries is governed by a model code called the International Building Code. The International Building Code, or IBC, is governed by a group of builders, architect,
两组或有时三组——男、女和残疾人，在这个重新构想的卫生间里，所有人都可以监控一个单一的公共空间。人们很快就会发现，这些是开放的空间，在某种意义上提供了“街上的双重眼睛”。所以这些卫生间复仇者击败了一个敌人，即“公共卫生间只能按性别隔离”的想法。但这在战争中还剩下一个前线，即法律前线，特里·科根与管理建筑规范的机构之间的战斗。美国几乎每个州和城市以及许多外国都受一种名为《国际建筑规范》的示范规范管理。《国际建筑规范》或IBC由一群建筑商、建筑师、
city planners, and other design experts who together make decisions that hopefully keep the public safe. Rules about stuff like light switches and handrails. This group gets together every three years to agree to changes to the code. To account for technological innovations and building innovations whatever. Terry and the other lawyers involved with the effort appealed to change the line of code requiring separate facilities. Terry told me there are some very practical, build-ery arguments that you can make in favor of inclusive design. You don't necessarily need to appeal to people's sense of equality. An all-gender multi-user restroom
城市规划师和其他设计专家管理，他们共同做出决定，希望保持公众安全。关于灯开关和扶手等东西的规则。这个小组每三年聚会一次，同意对规范进行修改。以适应技术创新和建筑创新等等。特里和参与这项工作的其他律师上诉要求修改要求独立设施的规范条款。特里告诉我，你可以提出一些非常实际的、建筑方面的论点来支持包容性设计。你不一定需要诉诸人们的平等感。一个全性别多用户卫生间
is a much more efficient use of space than sex-separated restrooms. They prepared their arguments for the committee in the lead-up to the big meeting about amending the code in the fall of 2018, then came a long wait until the decision finally became public this spring. And... And then in the next iteration of the code, the multi-user type that we champion will be code compliant. Meaning in the very dry language of code compliance, they won!
比按性别隔离的卫生间更有效地利用空间。他们在2018年秋季关于修改规范的大型会议前为委员会准备了论点，然后经过漫长的等待，直到决定在今年春天最终公开。而且……在下一版本的规范中，我们倡导的多用户类型将符合规范。这意味着用非常枯燥的规范合规语言来说，他们赢了！
So, starting soon, architects and builders will have greater freedom to choose this kind of bathroom. They won't be required to build sex-segregated bathrooms anymore. This development is a major step towards having more inclusive bathrooms in the world, but with some caveats. Like first off, it'll take some time for that new code to actually be adopted by local governments. And governing bodies at the city and state levels could also purposefully choose to ignore this particular update.
所以，从不久后开始，建筑师和建筑商将有更大的自由来选择这种卫生间。他们将不再被要求建造按性别隔离的卫生间。这一发展是世界上拥有更多包容性卫生间的重要一步，但也有一些注意事项。比如首先，新规范真正被地方政府采用还需要一些时间。城市和州一级的管理机构也可能故意选择忽略这一特定更新。
Now, they don't have to adopt it. Hookline and sinker. So, they conceivably could choose to leave out this exception. So, there is a chance that this single line of the building code could become a flashpoint, a new front in the culture wars. I guess my hope is that people will look at these redesigns and realize that this just makes so much more sense for everybody. Like, Sanny, I want this bathroom. Totally. It makes me think of something that Susan Striker said. What I feel is so elegant about the Stalled Public Toilet project is that at some
现在，他们不必全盘接受。所以，他们可以想象选择排除这个例外。因此，建筑规范的这一行文字有可能成为一个焦点，文化战争中的一个新前线。我想我的希望是人们会看到这些重新设计，并意识到这对每个人来说都更有意义。像桑迪一样，我想要这个卫生间。完全同意。这让我想起苏珊·斯特赖克说的一件事。我觉得Stalled公共厕所项目优雅的地方在于，在某种
level, it just, it doesn't matter. Like, it doesn't matter what most people think about, trans people, it doesn't matter. If you feel like you should accommodate people with disabilities, it's like, by the design of the space, it just solves the problem. And like, of course, I'd love if all people recognize that I am a full person deserving of rights and respect. My dream is to be walking down some airport terminal and to stumble upon a multi-user inclusive restroom
层面上，它只是……没关系。就像，大多数人对跨性别者的看法并不重要，没关系。如果你觉得你应该照顾残疾人，就像，通过空间的设计，它就解决了问题。而且，当然，如果所有人都能认识到我是一个拥有权利和尊严的完整的人，我会很高兴。我的梦想是走在某个机场航站楼里，偶然发现一个多用户包容性卫生间，
like the stalled one. I picture entering it, seeing that mirror of varying heights that unrelating countertop, the water wall, the plants. I envision entering one of those single-user stalls and locking it behind me. But you know for now, I'll just take a bathroom I can use. All right, I'm at Grand Central Station. Very beautiful. There are no bathrooms for me. I also wanted to buy a sandwich to eat on the train.
就像Stalled的那样。我想象着走进它，看到那个不同高度的镜子、那个不同高度的台面、水墙、植物。我设想走进那些单用户隔间之一，并在身后锁上门。但你知道，目前，我只要有一个我能用的卫生间就行了。好吧，我在中央车站。非常漂亮。这里没有我能用的卫生间。我还想买个三明治在火车上吃。
And realized I won't be able to wash my hands first. So I bought some purel and I'm going to put 10 that's like washing my hands. Okay, that's it. Music Okay, that's it. Coming up after the break, Sandy and I will discuss bathroom signage and the's wearing a dress. And that's the man's a dress wearing figure, and that's the man symbol and the woman symbol. But in like a really outdated stereotype you sense, it's like a picture of the concept
然后意识到我没法先洗手。所以我买了一些免洗洗手液，我要用它，那就像洗手一样。好吧，就这样。音乐。好吧，就这样。休息后回来，桑迪和我将讨论卫生间标志，以及那个穿着裙子的人。那是穿着裙子的男性形象，那是男性符号和女性符号。但在一种非常过时的刻板印象中，这就像是二元性别概念的图片。
of the binary gender. Well, that and, you know, even the most retrograde human alive today doesn't associate women with just wearing dresses. I mean, even if you were just to buy into the gender binary, wearing dresses is not just like this hallmark of womanhood, anyway. Yeah, so it's like gender in a 1950s sense. Totally, totally.
嗯，还有，你知道，即使是今天活着的最守旧的人也不会把女性仅仅与穿裙子联系起来。我的意思是，即使你只是相信性别二元论，穿裙子也不是女性气质的标志，无论如何。是的，所以这就像1950年代意义上的性别。完全是。
But it's something, you know, I've seen so often, and I think that maybe my sensitivity to it is sort of diminished because I kind of take it for granted that it is what it is. Right, and that's because it's pretty much everywhere, right? Like there are some variations, but across the US and my experience at least pretty much everywhere, it's some play on men's women's,
但这东西，你知道，我见过太多次了，我想也许我对它的敏感度降低了，因为我有点认为它是理所当然的。对，那是因为它几乎无处不在，对吧？就像有一些变化，但在美国各地，至少在我的经验中，几乎到处都是，它是男、女、
ladies and gents, you know, cowgirls and cowboys. Right. And it raised these questions like if we're moving towards more inclusive public restrooms, why not more inclusive public restrooms science? Like what would they look like? Exactly. And this is actually something that the Stalled team has thought about. How do we make a sign that's genuinely inclusive?
女士和先生，你知道，牛仔女郎和牛仔。对。这引发了这些问题，比如如果我们正朝着更具包容性的公共卫生间迈进，为什么不采用更具包容性的公共卫生间标志呢？它们会是什么样子？正是如此。这实际上是Stalled团队考虑过的事情。我们如何制作一个真正包容的标志？
And so they started out by analyzing the signs that are already out there. And one interesting thing they found is that bathroom signage really varies by geography. Here's Seb Chuggan. Like in many European countries, the restroom signage just says WC for water closet. And that's sufficient. We've been doing research on restrooms in South Africa and in other countries where the sanitation system is not at the Western standard and a lot of those times signage is sometimes not even present.
于是他们开始分析现有的标志。他们发现的一个有趣的事情是，卫生间标志确实因地理位置而异。这是塞布·查根。就像在许多欧洲国家，卫生间标志只是写着WC，代表水厕。这就足够了。我们一直在研究南非和其他卫生系统未达到西方标准的国家的卫生间，很多时候标志甚至不存在。
So I think it's important to remember that when we're talking about gender binary signage, it's definitely culturally and geographically relative. Yeah, and this is something I've definitely noticed. I mean, because where I live in the Bay Area, you do see some signs that don't rely on the gender binary for sure. Yeah, that's true. In some parts of the country, those liberal west coast cities, especially you'll see places turning single user stalls into what are sometimes labeled all gender restrooms. Or sometimes you'll see a sign that includes a male figure and a female one and a wheelchair,
所以我认为重要的是要记住，当我们谈论性别二元标志时，它绝对是文化和地理相对的。是的，这是我绝对注意到的。因为在我居住的湾区，你确实看到了一些不依赖性别二元论的标志。是的，没错。在该国的一些地区，特别是那些自由派的西海岸城市，你会看到一些地方将单用户隔间变成了有时被称为“全性别卫生间”的地方。或者有时你会看到一个标志，包括一个男性形象、一个女性形象和一个轮椅，
maybe accompanied by a phrase like gender neutral. I would say our team doesn't think that's the ideal sign either, because we're not really gender neutral. We don't want to neutralize gender because there are such rich expressions of that identity. And also of course, such as reinforces the gender binary by having that male and female figure
可能伴随着像“性别中立”这样的短语。我想说我们的团队也不认为那是理想的标志，因为我们并不是真正的性别中立。我们不想中和性别，因为这种身份有如此丰富的表达方式。而且，当然，通过拥有那个男性和女性形象，它强化了性别二元论，
and also others and segregates the wheelchair user, which is kind of this non-human character almost. It's not male, it's not female, it's this other category, almost like colored bathrooms where colored was its own category. And so as they did their research, what started to become clear to the stalled team was that wherever designers tend to rely on avatars, human
而且还隔离了轮椅使用者，这几乎是一个非人类的角色。它不是男性，不是女性，它是另一个类别，几乎就像“有色人种卫生间”，其中“有色人种”是它自己的类别。所以当他们进行研究时，Stalled团队开始清楚的是，无论设计师倾向于依赖化身、人类
figures, it seems like the icon will always fail to capture the complexity of humanity by implicitly leaving some folks out. In general, stalled does not advocate for using those gendered human avatars in bathroom signage at all. And instead, we advocate for inclusive restroom signage to use fixtures of what is included in the restroom, which can be as simple as a toilet icon. That's the huge revelation. Make the icon a toilet.
形象，图标似乎总是无法捕捉人类的复杂性，因为它隐含地将一些人排除在外。总的来说，Stalled根本不提倡在卫生间标志中使用那些有性别的化身。相反，我们提倡包容性卫生间标志使用卫生间内包含的设施，这可以简单到是一个马桶图标。这就是巨大的启示。把图标做成马桶。
I mean, it's really obvious. So the end of the day, if there's one piece of equipment that you expect to see in a public restroom that you really need, it is a toilet. So why not just depict a symbol of that? Yeah, and perhaps you'd want that sign to include other fixtures as well, depending on the situation. You can include other things, like a baby changing station or a sink icon. And I think this also makes the restroom more inclusive, not only by just saying clearly what is inside this
我的意思是，这真的很明显。归根结底，如果你在公共洗手间里最需要看到的一件设施，那一定是马桶。所以为什么不直接用它的符号来表示呢？是的，而且根据具体情况，你可能还希望标志能包含其他设施。你可以加入其他元素，比如婴儿护理台或洗手池图标。我认为这也能让洗手间更具包容性，不仅能清楚地说明里面有什么，
room you're about to enter, but also to not prioritize certain languages over others. Something that Seb points out is like, this doesn't have to be some top-down exercise where architects dictate to society what signs should be like. I see plenty of trans-inclusive signage on the internet of unicorns or aliens and saying whatever, just wash your hands or clever ways to denote that whoever is included. I honestly celebrate that and I don't want to flatten the creativity of graphic design by having this singular universal sign of a toilet that everyone has to use. I think it's fine for smaller establishments
而且不会让某种语言凌驾于其他语言之上。Seb 指出的一点是，这不必是一个自上而下的过程，不需要由建筑师来规定社会应该使用什么样的标志。我在网上看到了很多具有跨性别包容性的标志，比如独角兽或外星人，上面写着“随便洗手”或者用巧妙的方式来表示欢迎任何人使用。我真心赞赏这种做法，我不希望通过强制使用一个每个人都必须遵守的通用马桶标志，来抹杀平面设计的创造力。我认为对于小型场所来说，这样做是可以的，
to get creative with it as long as it's inclusive of everyone, but I think just as a best practice, a fixture is better than a woman in a dress. Oh, totally. I mean, anything's gotta be better than a woman in a dress. I do kind of wonder about that some of the really creative iconography could be a little flippant for something that's pretty serious. Like if you have like, you know, the man symbol, the woman symbol, and an alien symbol as if people don't finish those or aliens.
只要能包容所有人，发挥创意是没问题的。但我认为作为最佳实践，用设施图标比用穿裙子的女性形象更好。哦，完全同意。我的意思是，任何东西都比穿裙子的女性形象要好。我确实有点怀疑，一些非常有创意的图标对于严肃的场合来说是否显得过于轻浮。比如，如果你放上男人符号、女人符号和外星人符号，就好像人们不是人或者外星人一样。
You know what I'm saying? Absolutely. And that's something we talked about. And I think it's all about exactly are you being inclusive? And if you're making a man, woman, alien unicorn, you're ultimately, it's offensive, right? So I think it's like, it has a lot to do with like, taste and how people are choosing to, you know, I think really take that advice of opting to depict what's inside this room, rather than what sorts of bodies are allowed to use it. Yeah. Yeah. But it does seem like this is a really good moment to think about it as we're sort of like
你知道我的意思吗？当然。这也是我们讨论过的问题。我认为关键在于你是否真的做到了包容？如果你制作了男人、女人、外星人、独角兽的标志，最终这其实是一种冒犯，对吧？所以我认为这很大程度上与品味有关，以及人们如何选择去采纳那种建议，即选择描绘房间里有什么，而不是规定哪些身体被允许使用它。是的。是的。但这确实是一个很好的思考时机，因为我们正处于
entering public life a new kind of from this period of time of being kind of closed up in our own homes. It could be moment to have that kind of exploration right now. Yeah, something I've been thinking about is this is actually maybe a moment for small business owners, for example, to think about how to make their bathrooms more inclusive. And if you're one of those listeners who's actually seen an interesting, gender inclusive bathroom sign, take a picture of it and tweet it at us at 9iMPI.org.
重新进入公共生活的一种新阶段，从我们被关在自己家里的那段时期走出来。现在可能正是进行这种探索的好时机。是的，我一直在想，这实际上可能是一个让小企业主思考如何让他们的洗手间更具包容性的时刻。如果你是那些见过有趣的性别包容性洗手间标志的听众之一，请拍张照片并推特发给我们 @99pi.org。
And we're going to be collecting some unique samples and, you know, how people approach this design challenge. Well, thanks so much for talking with us, Andy. And thanks so much for the story. It's just been really illuminating and I learned so much and I really appreciate it. Thank you. Sandy Allen is an author. Their book is called A Kind of Miraculous Paradise. Learn more about their work at hellosandyallon.com 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Sandy Allen. Edited by Senior Producer Delaney Hall.
我们将收集一些独特的样本，看看人们是如何应对这一设计挑战的。非常感谢你与我们交谈，Andy。也感谢你带来的故事。这非常有启发性，我学到了很多，非常感谢。Sandy Allen 是一位作家。他们的书名为《一种奇迹般的天堂》(A Kind of Miraculous Paradise)。欲了解更多关于他们的作品，请访问 hellosandyallon.com。本周的《99% Invisible》由 Sandy Allen 制作，高级制作人 Delaney Hall 编辑。
Music by Sean Riel. Sound mix by Bryson Barnes. Special thanks this week by Sandy Allen, edited by Senior Producer Delaney Hall, music by Sean Riel, sound mix by Bryson Barnes. Special thanks this week to Vanessa Gonzalez, Martin Gonzalez, Andrea Smarten, and the whole team at Stalled. Kurt Colstead is the digital director of the rest of the team, is Vivian Leigh, Chris Baroube, Joe Rosenberg, and it fits Gerald, Katie Mingle, Abby Madon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is now distributed in multiple locations around North America, but in our hearts will always be. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California.
音乐由 Sean Riel 创作。声音混音由 Bryson Barnes 完成。本周特别感谢 Sandy Allen，由高级制作人 Delaney Hall 编辑，音乐由 Sean Riel 创作，声音混音由 Bryson Barnes 完成。本周特别感谢 Vanessa Gonzalez、Martin Gonzalez、Andrea Smarten 以及 Stalled 的整个团队。Kurt Colstead 是数字总监，团队其他成员包括 Vivian Leigh、Chris Baroube、Joe Rosenberg、Efit Gerald、Katie Mingle、Abby Madon、Sophia Klatsker 以及我 Roman Mars。我们是旧金山 91.7 K-A-L-W 的一个项目，在 Radio Row 制作，现在分发到北美多个地点，但在我们心中，它永远属于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。
We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listeners supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Fun mall at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99pi org, who on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find out how to pre-order the new 99% invisible book. It's called 99% Invisible City. It's out October 6th. It's all there at 99mpi.org slash book. And for all your other 99mpi needs, look no further than 99pi.org. Radio to be on. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是 PRX 旗下 RadioTopia 的骄傲成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性、听众支持、100% 艺术家拥有的播客组成的独立集体。详情请访问 radiotopia.fm。你可以在推特上关注我 @RomanMars，关注节目 @99pi.org，也可以在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上关注我们。你可以了解如何预订新的《99% Invisible》书籍，书名是《99% Invisible City》。它将于 10 月 6 日出版。所有信息都在 99pi.org/book。对于所有其他 99pi 的需求，请访问 99pi.org。RadioTopia，来自 PRX。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。